la campagne a beau être difficile pour
lui catherine tasca on est convaincu
manuel valls est à même de l'emporter la
sénatrice socialiste des yvelines en a
fait son favori pour le scrutin de cette
primaire loin devant benoît hamon
pourtant élu du département des yvelines
c'est un camarade nous respectons ses
choix qui ne sont pas les nôtres qui ne
sont pas les nôtres dont on dira pour
parler je dirais sans sans agressivité
qui lie à une bonne part d'utopie et un
comportement qui a été le sien et et
d'autres à l'égard de notre parti qui ne
nous paraît pas fidèle à l'histoire de
ce parti
l'ancien ministre de françois mitterrand
soutien de manuel valls elle estime
qu'il est aujourd'hui le seul à avoir la
stature d'un chef d'état dans le
deuxième débat il est le seul à avoir
prononcé le mot de culture et vous
comprenez que pour moi ça compte mais
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui parle de
l'europe de façon à la fois très très
réaliste mais également active avec
cette distribution de tracts les
militants entendent et clarifier les
propositions de leurs candidats un
candidat qui suscite l'intérêt du public
selon les gens effectivement demande à
connaître un peu plus aussi du programme
demande à connaître un peu plus des axes
qui vont être donnés durant la campagne
pour la presse et je pense que là du
coup le retour et précis parce que les
gens cherchent à connaître
reste que l'épisode de la gifle reçue
par l'ancien premier ministre mardi soir
pourrait laisser des traces manuel valls
et est annoncé en tête dans les sondages
à l'issue du premier tour mais battu au
second
que ce soit par arnaud montebourg benoît
hamon justement